[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
officer potter's
behavior would indicate that the
reasonable officer
in her position would not have perceived
that deadly force had been justified
continued arguments over police use of
force in minnesota versus kim potter
plus more news out of minnesota the one
thing that i can say is the possibility
of him getting more time and having to
serve more time um that's a good thing a
change of plea from ex-cop derrick
sheldon and former white house official
mark meadows in hot water over the
january 6 insurrection at the u.s
capitol will he face criminal charges
plus former governor andrew cuomo
ordered to forfeit millions of dollars
earned from his coven 19 book deal and
he doesn't have much time to comply law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin wednesday marks day six in the
trial of ex-minnesota cop kim potter
at the center of the questioning potters
claim that she accidentally pulled her
gun instead of her taser when she shot
dante wright during a traffic stop this
past april wednesday started with the
defense cross-examining taser trainer
sergeant michael peterson this as
there's been arguments over whether her
actions were actually justified
where the suspect has a bench warrant
for a gun charge they should make an
arrest yes
they can't let him go
no you also teach that when a gun is
involved
on a bench warrant that the officer
should be vigilant about another gun
being in the car at issue
absolutely or a gun being on the person
isn't that correct yes and you train
this over and over again right yes
because stopping someone in a car is one
of the most dangerous things you can do
yes
and police officers who aren't vigilant
and um
are not uh aware of the dangers can be
shot
yes have been
yes
in tuesday's redirect examination
prosecutors press peterson on his
experience training officers
sergeant peterson in all the
years that you've been working at the
brooklyn center police department
have you been aware of any other
officers who have drawn their handgun
when they meant to draw their taser
i don't
and in the scenario based training has
that ever happened
it's not a topic that i frequently think
about i would have to take a
considerable amount of time to to think
about that yeah i guess i'm just asking
if somebody has ever said you that's not
what i meant to do
i have conducted so many trainings
around so many trainings that
they
honestly all blurred together i couldn't
pick out a specific time
potter faces manslaughter charges after
the shooting death of wright in brooklyn
center minnesota officers say wright was
pulled over for an expired registration
tag at the time wright called his mother
and told her he was being pulled over
for an air freshener hanging from his
rear view mirror the whole incident was
caught on video on several officers body
cams that footage shows wright getting
in a scuffle with the officers as they
tried to arrest him after they
determined he had a warrant out for his
arrest then as wright gets back into his
car appearing to try and get away potter
shoots him in the chest he died as a
result of those injuries potter
maintains she pulled her handgun
accidentally instead of her taser
there's a debate over whether that
action was actually justified for the
department's policies
a familiar face from the derrick chauvin
trial also took the stand wednesday
prosecutors asked law and police policy
professor seth stoughton about potter's
use of force and whether it was
appropriate at the time
and in your review of all the materials
in this case is did you see any evidence
that
officer potter decided to use a
gun in this case instead of a taser
did i see evidence that she decided to
use a gun
i think the evidence that i've reviewed
suggested that she intended to use the
taser and not the firearm
the use of deadly force was not
appropriate
and the evidence suggests that a
reasonable officer in officers in
officer potter's position could not have
believed that it was proportional to the
threat at the time in other words the
use of force was apparently excessive
and inappropriate
joining us today is civil rights
attorney sue ann robinson and terry
austin terry most of the officers who
testified were reluctant to say anything
negative about potter's actions do you
think professor stalton helped the
prosecution today
he absolutely did there's no question
the prosecution had a very difficult
time with all of the police officers who
testified they were reluctant they were
hesitant it was like you were pulling
teeth from them the last thing they
wanted to do was to hurt officer potter
so they were being very calculated
finally when stouton got on the stand he
was able to say that the use of force
here by officer potter was inappropriate
and it was not reasonable that's the
first time that i think the prosecution
has gotten that out in such clear terms
no suanne i can't say in the end because
some of the testimony is still playing
out but who did professor stalin's
testimony help the most
so terry let's let's throw that question
to you at the end of the day who do you
think that testimony is helping the most
i think there's no question here again
brian that stoughton is helping the
prosecution and the defense when he was
being examined on cross-examination
earl grey was questioning him and he was
literally just attacking him talking
over him and frankly i don't think he
made any points if i'm sitting on that
jury i'm thinking to myself earl grey
you are not being fair with this witness
you are not allowing him to answer the
questions and frankly you are not
getting any substantive information from
him so prosecution win for this one yeah
maybe to your point they can see the
contrasting between how the officers
testified and how the use of force
expert testified and how that played out
overall thank you
in other news a 380 million dollar pail
is on the way for survivors of larry
nassar's decades of abuse
our own terry austin sat down with jamie
white an attorney that represents
several of the girls and women affected
this week survivors came to an agreement
with usa gymnastics and the united
states olympic and paralympic committee
this comes after nassar's reign of abuse
as the former u.s national gymnastics
team doctor spanning over several
decades nassar sexually abused more than
500 women and girls among the survivors
olympic gold medalist simone biles
michaela moroney and ali raisman
attorney jamie white tells our terry
austin the settlement is a small step
toward writing a big wrong
this is the only way historically that
institutions change
whether it's the catholic church whether
it's the boy scouts where we represent
several hundred
young men or you know in this particular
case it's it's not until you hit people
in their pocketbook that they understand
um
you know the importance of playing a
role especially when you are profiting
off of the name and likeness of young
people right
um so
whether it's by choice or by force i do
think that we're going to see change
this is a message to institutions all
over this country that you know if
you're going to bring young people into
your stead and you're going to profit
off of them whether it's in the context
of a 12-year-old running space in your
gym or whether it's simone biles and
having her face
on the um
on the front page to your benefit
if you do that you have a responsibility
you cannot allow profits to overcome
your responsibility
meanwhile nassar is serving a 60-year
sentence of child pornography charges he
is also sentenced in a state case of 40
to 175 years behind bars
still ahead on law and crime daily more
misfortune for mark meadows as the
former white house chief of staff faces
possible criminal charges but former
minneapolis police officer and convicted
murderer derek shogman changes his plea
to guilty law crimes angenet levy joins
us with those details next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back former minneapolis police
officer garrett shovin pleads guilty in
federal court in the death of george
floyd law and crime's angel levy is here
with the details of the plea
brian derek chauvin pleaded guilty to
violating the civil rights of george
floyd into also violating the rights of
a fourteen-year-old boy he arrested back
in 2017.
now this hearing took place in federal
court so cameras were not allowed but a
sketch artist captured some of it
chauvin appeared in an orange prison
jumpsuit next to his lawyer eric nelson
shovin's family sat behind him along
with attorneys for the other three
officers involved in floyd's arrest and
death in may of 2020. george floyd's
brothers were also in the courtroom
in exchange for pleading guilty chauvin
will be sentenced to between 20 and 25
years in prison that sentence would run
concurrently or at the same time as his
22 and a half year state prison sentence
chauvin will also serve his time in a
federal prison not a state prison
floyd's family and their lawyers spoke
after the hearing
i mean i'm still feeling the same pain
anger i felt in the beginning because he
could have did this last year we came
here just like we did before
we just wanted accountability because we
can never have justice because we can
never get george back he pleaded guilty
today
after putting this family through
a gut-wrenching trial where the jury
very quickly realized that he was guilty
of all charges and one of the most
catastrophic and egregious civil rights
violations that anyone has ever seen
now prosecutors plan to argue for a
sentence of 300 months that is 25 years
now had chauvin gone to trial and been
convicted which appears to be very
likely given the video evidence in this
case
he would have faced the possibility of a
life sentence brian
thanks internet let's bring back civil
rights attorney suanne robinson and
terry austin terry what sentence is
shogun facing we heard there that is a
possible 25 years that he's found guilty
of these two federal uh charges in one
state uh what is there a guideline or a
range that he's looking at
well yeah i mean he's looking at a range
because he's going to be considering
whether or not
there are any other factors to put into
that sentence but they know that it's
going to be at least 90 percent of what
he needs to serve before he can even get
out on probation and you know frankly i
think the fact that he
changed his plea from guilty to not
guilty was really a good thing as far as
the system was concerned but he really
didn't express any remorse brian and i
think that's the thing everyone was
looking for he answered all of the
prosecution's questions about whether or
not you held george floyd down yes you
know i did and the fact that he violated
his constitutional rights but all in all
i don't think that society is basically
satisfied with what he had to say during
the change in that plea no so and he's
been found good deal of state charges
pled guilty to federal where will
chauvin serve his time and how does that
work out
he is going to
serve his time in federal prison it's
going to be concurrent with his state
sentence and his federal sentence is
actually about two and a half years
longer than his state sentence so um you
know it's a win for him i guess in a way
because he's going to be in a federal
prison which the perception is that
he'll be safer because he wouldn't be
with potentially people in state prison
or state jail that he potentially put
there so he's safer in federal i think
he definitely
over promised and underperformed because
if you remember at the end of the state
trial when he was giving his statement
he told the family you know something
will be revealed later that will help
you to understand something or some sort
of cryptic thing he said and you know
there was nothing that happened today at
the federal sentencing that revealed
anything to any of us other than that
you know he took the plea and he's not
going to waste the
federal prosecutor's time yeah good
point we missed that little nugget that
he uh promised us and janet what about
the other three officers facing charges
king lane and tao what's next for them
well uh their state trial is scheduled
for march of 2022 we knew that that had
already been delayed and a trial date in
federal court has yet to be set and
derek chovin will actually be formally
sentenced at a later date brian
we'll see what that formal sentence ends
up being and how many years or months
depending on you break it down it will
be
o.j simpson is officially a free man as
his parole ends in nevada the former
football player actor and acquitted
murderer was
discharged from his parole two weeks ago
because of good behavior in 1997 simpson
was acquitted in the double murder of
his ex-wife nicole brown simpson and his
and her friend ronald goldman
it was called the trial of the century
he was later found liable for the deaths
and ordered to pay more than 33 million
dollars to the victims families 74 year
old simpson was released from a nevada
prison in october of 2017 after serving
time on separate charges simpson was
convicted by a las vegas jury after a
confrontation with sports collectible
dealers in a casino hotel in 2007. it
escalated quickly and ultimately left
simpson and five other men facing
robbery and kidnapping charges simpson
maintains he just wanted personal items
back ones he says were taken from him
after his acquittal of murder a decade
earlier
coming up on law and crime daily the man
who served under president trump as the
white house chief of staff is facing
possible criminal charges stemming from
the january 6 u.s capital attack
plus more problems for another
government official former governor
andrew cuomo ordered to pay back
millions of dollars to the state of new
york
[Music]
welcome back headed to washington now
where former white house chief of staff
mark meadows is one step closer to
facing criminal charges this after a
house vote late tuesday night u.s
representatives voted to approve the
so-called january 6 committee's
recommendation to hold medals in
contempt of congress for refusing to
testify under a subpoena this stems from
the investigation into the january 6
attack when a mob stormed the u.s
capitol following the 2020 election on
monday the committee released text
messages sent to meadows on january 6
from fox news host and donald trump jr
urging action from former president
trump meadows is the second official to
face criminal contempt steve bannon was
previously indicted after failing to
honor his subpoena in the investigation
it is now to the department of justice
to officially pursue criminal charges
back to break down the latest in the
january 6 committee is civil rights
attorney suen robinson and co-host terry
austin terry meadows mark oh sorry mark
meadows uh is
is has a second person to have these
charges on him do you think there will
be more in the future and what kind of
punishments could they face
oh i definitely think there will be more
in the future i think steve bannon you
mentioned was the first medals is the
second meadows is at least producing
documents he's refusing to show up so
there's no question that they were going
to hold him in contempt here and i think
as i said you'll see others he's facing
a maximum of 12 months in prison and a
hundred thousand dollars and a minimum
of one month so we'll see what happens
all of this means though he does not
still have to testify because they can't
compel his testimony all right so man
that's about testimony let's get to the
facts what do these text messages that
have surfaced so far really tell us
about the attack on the capitol
i think they tell us that there was an a
kind of like an underlying awareness
with all of them that this was going to
happen i mean obviously they had their
blogs and their different sites that
things were being coordinated and things
like that which has come out from the
individual participants but i think
everyone was still thinking that it was
a stretch to say that people were
involved at the highest level including
steve bannon and i think that's what the
text messages are revealing like what
was going on what they were thinking
what those sentiments were what they
were doing what they were saying and how
they were um aware that this was going
to happen all right let's continue to
see how this committee uncovers more
information and see if there will be
more contempt of congress charges thank
you both up next former new york
governor andrew cuomo was ordered to
return millions of dollars this after
allegedly using state resources to write
a book about leading during the coca-19
pandemic that's coming up next on long
crime daily
welcome back to long crime daily turning
now to news out of new york as the
state's former governor andrew cuomo is
ordered to pay back a large sum of money
he earned from his coven 19 pandemic
book deal they mount 5.1 million dollars
he has just 30 days to return the money
a public ethics commission previously
found cuomo used state resources while
writing his book american crisis
leadership lessons from the kova 19
pandemic cuomo's spokesperson maintains
anyone who contributed volunteered to do
so this is the latest fall from grace in
cuomo's saga as he now faces criminal
charges for allegedly inappropriately
touching a former assistant at the
executive mansion while in office and
that came just months after resigning
due to allegations of sexual harassment
and other scandals
suanne why can this ethics committee go
after the money cuomo made on his book
deal
because they're essentially saying it
was earned during his tenure and that he
used material obviously from while he
was serving to essentially profit from
that and so they're basically clawing
that back i think that you know the the
committee has just decided that
obviously he's persona non grata based
on what he's accused of doing and
they're just making sure that you know
he is not profiting or profiting or
benefiting from anything he did
during that period of time when he was
serving as governor yeah interesting
because it is a committee that i think
he may have started and also like help
run while he was in office uh terry
coleman was like he gonna fight this uh
what does that fight look like
he is going to fight this hard and
suanne is right they are coming after
him in every direction this is going to
be a he said she said there are no
videos there's no witnesses here so it's
basically going to be an avalanche of
evidence as far as emails are concerned
as far as texts are concerned we know
that the attorney general has a lot of
information in her report so that will
be something that i think he's going to
have to deal with based on what we've
heard so far he's going to try to say
his actions are innocent and
unintentional and he's going to argue
that the accusers basically are either
lying or they you know provided consent
all right we'll see how this plays out
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you